Ace was CRIMINALLY nerfed by the author of
One Piece.
That’s right.
I said it.
Honestly, looking at what we know about Ace,
he had the potential to become one of the
strongest characters in the entire story.
However, because Luffys is the main character,
Ace not only never got to show his true power
even once, but he even had his life BRUTALLY
cut short.
However, let’s pretend THIS never happened
[Donut Ace] and instead figure out what would
happen if Ace reached his full potential.
Because picture this.
Seventeen year old Ace becomes a pirate.
He gets his fire devil fruit and starts to
make a real name for himself in the pirate
world.
He LITERALLY travels the ENTIRE Grand Line,
going from places like Fishman Island all
the way to Wano where he rescued children
from Kaido’s castle.
Seriously, this man is the DEFINITION of THAT
GUY.
And before he even turned twenty he defeated
a Warlord and fought another one for five
whole days.
But then what happens next DESTROYED Ace’s
chance of becoming pirate king.
Because then Whitebeard showed up [ch 552],
beat down Ace, and basically forced the fiery
young pirate onto his crew.
Now, without a doubt, this worked out well
for Ace.
He found the family he had always wanted and
was happy all the up until his death at Marineford.
BUT…
And this is a big BUT, Ace joining Whitebeard’s
crew was the DEATH of his chances at growing
stronger because at this point he didn’t
really have to struggle on his own anymore.
So yeah, being with Whitebeard definitely
killed Ace’s true potential.
That’s all in the past though, because let’s
imagine that Ace’s story went in a completely
new direction.
Originally, Ace fought the Warlord Jinbe for
five days before Whitebeard showed up, so
instead of that let’s imagine that Ace defeats
Jinbe sooner and then he and his crew sailed
away before the Yonko arrived to wipe them
all out.
Or if this is too unreasonable for you, maybe
Whitebeard does show up and beat down Ace,
but instead of inviting him on the crew maybe
Whitebeard recognizes Ace’s potential and
lets him go.
And if this happened then Ace would be FURIOUS
that he couldn’t defeat Whitebeard, which
means he is going to want to get even stronger.
Maybe he’ll just continue to train on his
own or even seek out someone to help him reach
the next level.
Either way, here’s the deal.
Ace is now around twenty years old, and let’s
say after some more time on his own he’s
learned basic armament and observation haki,
since that was never confirmed in the story.
So Ace is already stronger than he was originally.
So now you might be asking, what is Ace’s
goal since he isn’t part of Whitebeard’s
crew anymore?
Well, the answer is simple, because if you
read the Ace novels then you should know that
his main goal after entering the Grand Line
was to defeat the Yonko.
He even burned down Whitebeard’s flag in
fishman island when the Spade Pirates passed
through on their way to the new world.
So everything that Ace does at this point
will be to grow stronger so that he can defeat
the Yonko.
Before we go any further though, let’s recap
where we are timeline wise.
At this point, Ace has been a pirate for around
three years, which is the same time that Luffy
starts his own adventure.
However, there are some serious changes to
this story since Ace didn't join Whitebeard.
Basically, the whole Marineford Saga is cut
out of the story because that entire plot
line started when Ace hunted down Blackbeard
because he betrayed Whitebeard's crew by backstabbing
this guy [ch 440, Thatch].
This time around, Ace just doesn't care though,
so there's no getting captured by Blackbeard.
Although, Blackbeard might go after Luffy
even more than he already did, but Luffy already
escaped from Blackbeard the first time [ch
236] so I’m not going to assume that the
wanna be Emperor would catch Luffy in the
first place.
Plus, Whitebeard wouldn’t come to Marineford
to save Luffy anyway, so there wouldn’t
be a giant battle unless Shanks or Luffy’s
father came to save him.
But we’re getting way too off track here.
This video is about Ace, not Luffy.
But what all this means is that Whitebeard
will still be alive.
However, that won’t last for long.
Because let’s assume that after the years
of extra training, Ace finally feels like
he is ready to take on Whitebeard.
So the Spade pirates roll up and challenge
the Emperor.
And while Ace’s crewmates might get completely
wiped out, I do think Ace would be strong
enough at this point to take out Whitebeard.
Because remember, Whitebeard is still sick,
and the longer he is in the story, the worse
he is going to get.
He’s still incredibly powerful though, and
it would be a legendary fight with Whitebeard’s
Tremor powers against Ace’s supercharged
fire blasts.
And during the fight, I can easily see Whitebeard
being reminded of Roger while fighting Ace
which might lead to Ace revealing that he
is actually Roger’s son.
And can you imagine that?
That single fact would just completely blow
Whitebeard’s mind AND it is going to change
the rest of Ace’s story forever.
Because let’s just imagine that after an
exhausting battle, Ace finally defeats the
sick Whitebeard, but because of the respect
they gained for each other, Ace spares Whitebeard’s
life.
However, this is where things turn dark.
Because just like at Marineford, I can imagine
Blackbeard swooping in and finishing off Whitebeard
to steal his devil fruit.
And since the Emperor and Ace just had their
big, exhausting battle, it makes a lot of
sense to me that Whitebeard and his crew wouldn’t
be able to fight them off.
So yeah, I do see Blackbeard once again killing
Whitebeard and taking his devil fruit.
Shocking, right?
However, one important thing to add is that
I think with his dying breath, Whitebeard
might try to inspire Ace to find the One Piece
just like he originally did when he gave his
famous “The One Piece is real” line during
Marineford [ch 576].
He might even tell Ace the importance of what
Roger discovered or that Ace needs to find
the One Piece.
So while Ace might not really know exactly
what Whitebeard is talking about, I honestly
think this would have a major impact on the
young pirate.
And while he might not want to follow in his
father’s footsteps, I could see Ace ultimately
deciding to inherit Whitebeard’s dying will.
Which is just incredibly ironic because Whitebeard
originally wanted Ace to be pirate king, but
the Emperor held Ace back by making him join
his crew.
But now that Ace is on his own, he could very
well be inspired to do exactly what Whitebeard
wanted him to do in the first place.
So yeah, Ace has a new goal and a new sworn
enemy in Blackbeard.
But with Whitebeard out of the picture, we
have to consider who would fill the void in
the Emperor Ranks.
It could be Blackbeard just like normal or
it could also be Ace, since he defeated Whitebeard
in the first place.
For now, let’s go with Ace being considered
an Emperor of the Sea, because come on, it
is just so incredibly cool to have Yonko Ace.
Now of course, the first part of Ace’s new
mission to become pirate king is to reach
Laugh Tale, but the surprising thing you have
to remember is that very few people in the
one piece world actually know how to even
find the directions to the legendary island.
So to start Ace would need to do one of two
things.
First, someone could tell him about the poneglyphs
and how you have to collect all four Road
Poneglyphs to reach Laugh Tale.
And this could be someone like Marco, who
has been with Whitebeard long enough to most
likely know about the Poneglyphs.
Honestly, though, that shortcut route feels
a bit cheap so let's go with the true way
which is that someone is supposed to find
the final island of the Grand Line, Loadstar
island.
This is the island where Roger and his crew
originally learned about the poneglyphs, so
let’s set Ace on that same path and say
that the Spade pirates sail past all of the
other Yonko’s territory and reach Lodestar.
This is where we have to start guessing though
because we don’t actually know what is on
Lodestar island.
It could be a poneglyph which explains all
about the other poneglyphs, including the
Road Poneglyphs which lead to Laugh Tale.
Or it could be some sort of ancient civilization
still living on Loadstar who helps guide people
to find the poneglyphs.
But whatever the case, there is one major
problem for Ace and the Spade pirates.
Which is that even if Ace finds the Poneglyphs,
he doesn’t have anyone who can actually
read them.
So to solve this, let’s just imagine that
Ace inherited his father’s Voice of All
Things ability, which lets Ace somewhat understand
what the poneglyphs say.
And although this doesn’t solve the problem
for good, this is enough for them to start
their journey collecting poneglyphs back at
the start of the Grand Line.
This leads to my personal favorite part of
this scenario which is when Ace reunites with
Luffy.
And oh, boy this is going to be fun.
And while they probably wouldn’t meet at
Alabasta since the timing is way different
here, Ace would still likely visit many of
the same places that Luffy did early on in
his journey.
For example, there was a poneglyph in Alabasta
and another on Fishman island.
So eventually, I would imagine that they meet
up, just like they did in the original story
[ch 157].
What’s really interesting though is that
when these two originally met they had this
interesting conversation about becoming pirate
king.
Obviously, that is Luffy’s goal, but now
Ace himself is on that same path and he has
a WAY BIGGER head start.
So even though these two friends are now technically
rivals, I just think that Luffy is nowhere
near strong enough yet to be a serious threat
to Ace, so Ace would likely just move on with
his journey.
Although, there is one HUGE CONFLICT that
will need to be addressed at some point.
Because even though Ace has the Voice of All
Things, that really isn’t enough to truly
interpret the Road Poneglyphs and reach Laugh
Tale.
Even Roger needed someone who could actually
read them in order to find the legendary island
[ch 966 Roger talking with Oden, Whitebeard].
And with Nico Robin being the only person
we know at this point in the story who could
read the poneglyphs, Ace would surely want
her to be on his crew.
So there’s a chance he could try to take
her OR that Robin herself might want to go
with Ace.
But for now let’s assume Ace doesn’t know
about Robin’s ability to read the Poneglyphs,
or that Robin is already invested in the Straw
Hats, so Ace simply moves on.
For now…
Now, Ace is well on his way to becoming pirate
king, but this journey is going to lead him
back to the New World.
And let’s assume this takes a long time,
at least a year or two as the Spade Pirates
continue their journey.
It’s not like there’s a map or anything
that shows where all the important poneglyphs
are.
Unless…
Wait, maybe there is.
Which would be completely awesome, but we
don’t know for sure.
Also keep in mind we are missing some major
world events here, like no marineford as we
said earlier, which also means no normal timeskip
for the straw hat crew, although I would imagine
Luffy and his crew would need some kind of
training arc in order to survive in the New
World.
But all this means that as Ace is collecting
the poneglyphs and searching for Laugh Tale,
he would 100% need to eventually fight Big
Mom and Kaido since they possessed two of
the Road Poneglyphs.
And before that let’s assume that Ace somehow
found his way to Zou and was able to get a
copy of the Road Poneglyph there.
I mean, I’m not really sure how that would
happen since the Spade pirates don’t have
a mink on their crew, but who knows maybe
they get a new crewmate along the way who
is a mink.
Or maybe they use their connections with their
friends on Wano to find someone who can take
them there.
But with that one out of the way, we now have
to face Big Mom and Kaido.
Certainly, the Spade pirates themselves are
not all that powerful, which would mean Ace
would need to basically be strong enough to
take on the entire Yonko crew.
Which I don’t know if Ace is THAT strong.
Which means it makes perfect sense for Ace
to team up with another pirate who has the
same goal.
Oh, I don’t know, maybe someone like Luffy!
That’s right because by this time the Straw
Hat pirates have entered the New World.
And you might think it is cheating for them
to team up, but we already know Luffy teamed
up with a lot of pirates to take down Kaido,
so I think it’s fair for Luffy and Ace to
work together to defeat the current Emperors.
Plus, Ace already has ties to Wano from his
time there early in his pirate career, so
let’s just say that instead of Luffy teaming
up with Kid and Law, Ace joins the party to
take down the Yonko.
This could happen separately on Whole Cake
Island and then Wano, or the Emperors could
team up like they did during the Wano arc.
And I don’t think it really matters who
fights who at this point, but the important
thing is that with their combined forces and
the people of Wano, Luffy and Ace should be
strong enough to take down Kaido and Big Mom.
The major, unavoidable problem is coming up
next though.
Because at this point both Ace and Luffy have
three Road Poneglyphs.
Ace is a legitimate Yonko and Luffy has just
awakened Gear 5.
However, Luffy has one major advantage over
Ace.
Nico Robin.
Because certainly at this point Ace would
realize that the Voice of All Things simply
isn’t enough to figure out how to get to
Laugh Tale.
He probably needs to know exactly what the
Road Poneglyphs say, so he desperately needs
someone on his crew who can read them.
Now there is this guy [Sukiyaki ch 1053],
but I doubt he wants to leave Wano, so that
just leaves one person who can read them.
Now, of course I doubt Robin would want to
go with Ace, but if Ace truly is determined
to become pirate king, then he will stop at
nothing to fulfill his goals.
Which ultimately means that these two crews
will need to fight.
Yeah, shocking right?
But that’s what it takes to become pirate
king.
And I can just imagine Luffy and Ace going
all out against each other.
Ace’s flames would be extremely powerful
by this point.
He is basically like a full on fiery god,
but Luffy also has his Gear 5 powers, which
as we’ve seen can let him take out even
the strongest of characters.
So I really don’t know how this battle would
go.
But in the end, I seriously doubt they would
go all the way to killing each other.
In fact, they might even decide to end this
fight in one of the most controversial ways
possible.
Let me explain.
If you go back to the arc just after Skypeia,
we were introduced to the concept of a Davy
Back Fight.
Now this is a real pirate competition in the
One Piece world where pirate crews can challenge
each other in order to steal members from
each other’s crews.
And as silly as this arc was, it really seems
like pirates take this seriously, and there
is even speculation that the legendary pirate
Rocks D. Xebec used Davy Back fights to gather
his impressive crew.
So anyway, you might be wondering, “what
exactly is a Davy back fight”?
Well, we’ve only seen one in the main story,
but it involved a three stage competition.
First a boat race around an island [ch 307].
A game called Groggy Ring [ch 309], which
is kinda like soccer except that one player
on each team is the ball.
And finally a one on one duel where the person
who gets knocked out of the ring first loses
[ch 313-314].
And of course, the winner of these events
gets to take members from the other person’s
crew.
Now, we aren’t sure if this is how every
single davy back fight works since we’ve
only seen one in the entire story, but for
the sake of this video, let’s assume that
Ace and the Spade pirates win this event,
and Nico Robin is forced to join Ace’s crew.
We could even say that the entire Straw Hats
are forced to join the Spade pirates, but
I’m not actually sure if Luffy would ever
work under someone else, so for now let’s
just assume that Robin is the one that joins
the Spade Pirates.
So that means that Ace now has a clear path
toward becoming pirate king.
All he has to do is find the fourth Road poneglyph,
which is likely being protected by the Emperor
Shanks and the giants in Elbaf, and then make
his way to Laugh Tale.
And while that is no easy task, we do know
that Ace already knows Shanks [ch 552], so
while I don’t think that Shanks would just
give Ace the Road Poneglpyh, if we can imagine
that Luffy would somehow obtain it from Elbaf
then the same applies to Ace.
There is just one other major problem though
because in all this time we still have the
MASSIVE threat of Blackbeard who will likely
be Ace’s final challenge before becoming
pirate king.
But with all that’s gone on in the story,
plus Ace’s extra motivation to take down
the person who killed Whitebeard, I just have
to imagine that Ace would come out on top.
Which just shows how much potential Fire-Fist
Ace truly had.
Actually though, this brings me to another
character with INSANE untapped potential.
Because if you’ve ever thought that it is
SO CRIMINALLY UNFAIR that Luffy and Zoro get
all the attention from the Straw Hats, you
are not alone.
Because Sanji is just as deserving as the
other two, so to hype him up even more, I
figured out the perfect devil fruit to make
Sanji into a god-tier fighter.
And you can watch that video right here.
Shanks for watching and I’ll see you in
the next one.